thirty to forty million americans grind
their teeth at night
that's roughly ten percent of the u.s.
population and chronic teeth grinding
can lead to painful issues from tenth
fractures to changes in facial
appearance but the worst part is you
could be a teeth grinder and not even
know it
[Music]
every time a grinder Nashes their back
molars together they exert as much as
200 pounds of pressure per square inch
that's ten times the force you exert on
your teeth when you chew normally this
pressure can crack and fracture teeth
and eventually even wear them down to
stumps which can then require root
canals implants or dentures but it's not
just your teeth that take a beating if
you suffer from chronic grinding also
called bruxism in the medical community
you could be grinding your teeth for up
to 40 minutes for every hour you're
asleep that's enough to cause headaches
and a sore jaw in the morning and if you
keep it up night after night it could
permanently damage your jaw researchers
estimate that 20% of teeth grinders have
symptoms of a painful jaw condition
called t md t md effects the movement of
your temporomandibular joints these
joints connect your jaw to your skull
helping you eat chew and talk but when
you grind your teeth incessantly you can
overwork these joints one study found
that when these muscles work overtime
they become tender and enlarged making
your face look more square and masculine
what's more the sound of grinding teeth
could be enough to damage your hearing
researchers who examined 400 University
students found a strong correlation
between grinding and tinnitus tinnitus
is a hearing condition that causes
ringing in your ears and can lead to
hearing loss but perhaps the scariest
part of all of this unless your roommate
or partner hears you grinding your teeth
at night you might not even realize
you're doing it until your dentist
notices the damage and chances are
you've probably done it yourself
an estimated 85 to 90% of the population
will grind or clench their teeth to some
degree and while there's no simple cure
for bruxism there's still hope a mouth
guard for instance won't stop you from
grinding altogether but it will stop
your molars from wearing your teeth down
to stumps and since grinding is often
caused by stress and anxiety some
doctors recommend counselling and
meditation so maybe a solution to your
teeth grinding problem is a nice long
vacation doesn't sound too bad right